Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Genetic algorithms help us solve problems
that are very difficult, if not impossible
to otherwise write programs for.
For instance, in this application, we have
to build a simple car model to traverse this
terrain. Put some number of wheels on it somewhere,
add a set of triangles as a chassis, and off
you go. This is essentially the DNA of a solution.
The farther it goes, the better the car is,
and the goal is to design the best car you
possibly can.
First, the algorithm will try some random
solutions, and, as it has no idea about the
concept of a car or gravity, it will create
a lot of bad solutions that don't work at
all.
However, after a point, it will create something
that is at least remotely similar to a car,
which will immediately perform so much better
than the other solutions in the population.
A genetic algorithm then creates a new set
of solutions, however, now, not randomly.
It respects a rule that we call: survival
of the fittest. Which means the best existing
solutions are taken and mixed together to
breed new solutions that are also expected
to do well. Like in evolution in nature, mutations
can also happen, which means random changes
are applied to the DNA code of a solution.
We know from nature that evolution works extraordinarily
well, and the more we run this genetic optimization
program, the better the solutions get. It's
quite delightful for a programmer to see their
own children trying vigorously and succeeding
at solving a difficult task. Even more so
if the programmer wouldn't be able to solve
this problem by himself.
Let's run a quick example.
We start with a set of solutions - the DNA
of a solution is a set of zeros and ones,
which can encode some decision about the solution,
whether we turn left or right in a maze, or
it can also be an integer or any real number.
We then compute how good these solutions are
according to our taste, in the example with
cars, how far these designs can get.
Then, we take, for instance, the best 3 solutions
and co mbine them together to create a new DNA
Some of the better solutions may remain
in the population unchanged. Then, probabilistically,
random mutations happen to some of the solutions,
which help us explore the vast search space
better.
Rinse and repeat, and there you have it. Genetic
algorithms.
I have also coded up a version of Roger Alsing's
EvoLisa problem where the famous Mona Lisa
painting is to be reproduced by a computer
program with a few tens of triangles. The
goal is to paint a version that is as faithful
to the original as possible. This would be
quite difficult for humans, but apparently
a genetic algorithm can deal with this really
well. The code is available for everyone to
learn, experiment, and play with. It's super
fun.
And if you're interested in the concept of
evolution, maybe read the excellent book,
The Blind Watchmaker by Richard Dawkins.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!